it is with humility and gratitude that
we stand here together to receive this
award on behalf of the European Union at
a time of uncertainty this day reminds
people across Europe in the world of the
union's fundamental purpose to further
the fraternity between European nations
now and in the future it is our work
today it has been the work of
generations before us and it will be the
work of generations after us here in
Oslo I want to pay homage to all the
Europeans who dreamt of a continent at
peace with itself and to all those who
day by they make this dream a reality
this award belongs to them
war is as old as Europe our continent
bears the scars of Spears and sorts of
cannons and guns of trenches and tanks
and more the tragedy of it all resonates
in the worlds of Herodotus 25 centuries
ago in peace sense bury their fathers in
war feathers bury their sons yet after
two terrible Wars and gallop the
continent and the world with it finally
lasting peace came to Europe as a child
born in Belgium just after the war I
heard the stories firsthand
my grandmother spoke about the Great War
and in 1940 my father then 17 had to dig
his own grave
he got away otherwise I would not be
here today ladies and gentlemen what a
ball bat it was for Europe's founders to
say yes yes we can break this endless
cycle of virus we can stop the logic of
vengeance we can build a brighter future
together what power of imagination and
to me what makes it so special is
reconciliation in politics as in life
reconciliation is the most difficult
thing
it goes beyond forgiving and forgetting
or simply turning the page to think of
what France and Germany had gone through
and then take this step signing a treaty
of friendship
each time I hear these words front shaft
am ETA I am moved four people Europe was
a promise Europe equaled hope when
Konrad Adenauer came to Paris to
conclude the coal and steel treaty in
1951 one evening he found a gift waiting
at his hotel it was a war medal in Croix
de Guerre that had belonged to a French
soldier and his daughter a young student
had left it with a little note for the
Chancellor as a gesture of
reconciliation and of hope
I can see many other stirring images
before me leaders of the six states
assembled to open a new future in Rome
Cheeta eterna willebrandt kneeling down
in Warsaw the Dockers of dunks the gates
of the shipyards mataró and coal
hand-in-hand two million people linking
Tallinn to Riga to Vilnius in a human
chain in 1989 and these moments these
moments healed Europe
but symbolic gestures alone cannot
cement peace this is where the European
Union's secret weapon comes into play an
unrivaled way of binding our interest so
tightly that war becomes materially
impossible to constant negotiations on
ever more topics between evermore
countries and it's the golden rule of
Romani Mew for a dispute a toad in table
basura Shawn Tabata better fight around
the table than on a battlefield if you
had to explain it to Alfred Nobel I
would say not just a peace Congress a
perpetual peace Congress admittedly some
aspects can be personally and not only
to outsiders ministers from landlocked
countries passionately discussing fish
quota euro parliamentarians from
Scandinavia debating the price of olive
oil the Union has perfected the art of
compromise
ladies and gentlemen it worked
peace is now self-evident war has become
inconceivable yet inconceivable does not
mean impossible and that is why we are
gathered here today Europe must keep its
promise of peace I believe this is still
our union's ultimate purpose but Europe
can no longer rely on this promise alone
to inspire citizens in a way it's a good
thing war memories of fading Soviet rule
over Eastern Europe and it just two
decades ago and horrendous massacres
took place in the Balkans shortly after
the children born at the time of Sabine
Itza will only turn 18 next year but
they already have little brothers and
sisters born after that war the first
real post-war generation of Europe and
this this must remain so
presidents prime ministers excellencies
so where there was war there is no peace
but another historic task now lies ahead
of us keeping peace where there is peace
after all history is not a novel a book
we can close after a happy ending we
remain fully responsible for what is yet
to come this couldn't be more clear than
it is today when you are hit by the
worst economic crisis in two generations
causing great hardship among our people
and putting the political bonds of our
union to the tests parents struggling to
make ends meet workers recently laid off
students who fear that however hard they
try they won't get their first job when
they think about Europe peace is not the
first thing that comes to mind when
prosperity and employment the bedrock of
our societies appear threatened it is
natural to see a hardening of hearts the
narrowing of interest even the return of
long-forgotten fault lines and
stereotypes for some not only joint
decisions but the very fact of deciding
jointly may come into doubt ladies and
gentlemen we answer without deeds
confident we will succeed we are working
very hard to overcome the difficulties
to restore growth and jobs there is of
course sheer necessity but there is more
that guides us the will to remain
masters of our own destiny a sense of
togetherness and in a way speaking to us
from the centuries the idea of Europa
itself
the presence of so many European leaders
here today and the lines a common
conviction that we will come out of this
together together and stronger strong
enough in the world to defend our
interests and promote our values we all
work to leave a better Europe for the
children of today and those of tomorrow
so that later
others might earn and judge that
generation ours preserved the promise of
Europe excellencies ladies and gentlemen
our continent risen from the ashes after
1945 and United in 1989 has a great
capacity to reinvent itself it will also
be for the next generation to take this
common adventure further
I hope they will seize this
responsibility with pride and that they
will be able to say as we hear today ich
bin ein repair
yes we share data or opium
I'm proud to be European
you